my name is reggie leflore i'm a visual
artist just based in twin cities
minnesota primarily use spray paint and
acrylic paints and inspired by
street art culture illustration graffiti
comic books all that sort of stuff we're
here at the northeast ice arena painting
a reference of matt dumbo on a 12 by 8
foot panel project here next to the ice
rink i really wanted to uh create
something that referenced who he is you
know just really just in the action and
the thick of you know being you know a
hockey player being the athlete but also
pay homage to
a lot of his influences that really
helped him understand like the more
diverse and more inclusive aspects of
hockey leagues and what he's doing
during this pandemic
something unexpected but long overdue
occurred
the world woke up
to the existence of systematic racism
and how deeply rooted it is within our
society racism is a man-made creation
and all it does is deteriorate from our
collective prosperity on behalf
of the nhl and the hockey diversity
alliance
we vow and promise to stand up for
justice
and fight for what is right
i hope this inspires a new generation
of hockey players
and hockey fans
because
black lives matter
brianna taylor's life matters
hockey is a great game
but it could be a whole lot greater
and it starts with all of us you know
we're trying to create our own
grassroots programs um just to help the
kids partnering up and creating an
alliance like the hockey diversity
alliance with my good friends um in the
nhl just combat racism in our sport i
think it's been really powerful that's
what my focus has been on these past uh
two years you know devoted my time and
you know my efforts in the community to
you know helping the next generation so
i think this is super cool opportunity
we have to to create some awareness and
do something that you know the kids can
relate to you know that other
alternative ways to be successful in
life and stuff and you doing that
through hockey i have some opportunities
to do that with my work as an artist you
know it came from folks that i've
learned from as well uh growing up in
many ways you know i feel like you know
there's a really strong representation
that i have you know for black and
marginalized folks to be an artist you
know travel the world and
use my experiences as an artist to you
know bring
you know forth awareness to things to
other people and opportunities to other
people and so one of the ideas that i
have for this project
is to really you know just try to create
something that reflects that diversity
and inclusion you know why don't we tap
into our youth you know why don't we tap
into you know this next generation of
folks that
well
i you know would in in my hope you know
to to be that pillar you know of you
know diversity you know within hockey
diversity with within the arts it made
this thing wavy i've seen some of your
work it's a beautiful man and i
appreciate that thank you inspiration
behind your art is super powerful people
put that in a rink i think that would be
that would be really cool for them to
see you know people say this all the
time that representation matters when i
look back at my childhood without even
knowing as as a young kid playing hockey
how much it matters and how true that
statement is my favorite two players
were paul korea and jerome mcginlan two
guys that
you know i could just i could relate to
because they look like me i wanted to
learn more about them and just study the
way they played and see these guys from
just different ethnicities playing in
you know a white sport it was really
cool and i
just honed in on those guys and followed
them without even kind of realizing how
much that you know made a difference
inspired me and you know takes my game
to another level and seeing that there's
other guys like me doing it i think
you're on the i think you're on the
right track bro hopefully have some kids
here uh from the cities you know chase
down their dreams matt you just have my
absolute gratitude you know for
everything that you're doing it's an
incredibly inspirational thing to see
that you've decided to use your platform
as a means to deliver a message and
you know deliver
you know a stance on things how
challenging
it is to really like talk about
diversity and inclusion and you just
have my thanks man so thank you
so sick
oh my god i would have to see that
closer man
wow that's unbelievable man i know i'm
kind of speechless
i didn't uh
i didn't think he would uh involve me
like that in the in the mural wow that's
uh well what an honor he's uh
why was he talented that's super cool